do you think
jesse
was pretending like he was your friend
but then he was
hooking up
with this woman that you were in love
with
uh i don't know probably probably it was
a motive of trying to just
be relevant on the show and get in
somebody else's business and just try to
be relevant because you know his his
ex-girlfriend is doing a lot better than
him that's probably all it was and then
he was just like getting all into my
business you know i'm gonna tell you i
don't i don't i don't hate him as a
person i just and i don't i don't have
any bad feelings or vibes with him or
anything because i don't know him that
well i just don't like the words that
comes out of his mouth that's the only
problem i don't like because he's he's
too nosy he doesn't need to be in my
business he needs to mind his own
business and he needs to just stay in
his own lane so why did you block him on
social media you know why because
because i do not need any negativity in
my life right now
all right well uh you're blocking 90
dayers but you are dm'ing with
celebrities i understand you've been uh
getting messages from drake is that
right
yeah yeah we're pretty good friends yeah
yeah he saw my story and um and then he
uh he messaged me and he was like hey
sees you know how you doing um
we just started becoming friends and he
sent me some of his clothing from his
clothing line drake sent you clothing
uh-huh yeah and i posted up on my
instagram yeah he's an awesome person
okay you said you're pretty good friends
how good
once in a while we'll we'll call each
other see how we're doing you've got
drake's number yeah yeah we'll call each
other you know and he'll call me and say
hey sees how are you doing what's going
on have you been he calls you seats
drake calls caesar sneeze
yara what do you think about this so
from one side i really love drake and
wanna believe that but after what maria
and other women did to caesar i'm
thinking if that's a real drink now
but if it's a real drake i think this
sounds so much cool because i love him
okay what do you think about
caesar
hooking up with drake who is drake
oh my goodness
now drake is
i'm sorry
i love
i just make face all the time look like
i know what's going on right now and i
think if you don't ask me this question
i'm thinking yeah drake yes i know him
pretty nice guy and you're asking me
like i said damn julia you don't know
drake you're not my friend anymore i'm
done with you how you cannot know who is
drake
[Music]